- Today's session, you're gonna get
to hear from two large
enterprise customers
about how they use SAP as
well as AI to transform
and to innovate for their business.
You're gonna hear from Gustav Hilding,
who's the Chief Technical
Architect at Axfood.
Axfood is a large grocery retailer
that's headquartered in Sweden.
You're gonna hear from Varada Reddy.
Varada is the Director of SAP
Technology and Transformation
at Harman International.
Harman is a pro and consumer audio company
that owns well-known brands
such as JBL speakers,
and Marantz stereos, and many more.
My name's Eric Kamman.
I am a member of our
worldwide SAP on AWS team.
We have more than 7,000 customers
today that run SAP in AWS.
I lead a team of solution architects
that are focused on building
solutions, and services,
and guidance to support
all of our SAP customers
on their journey to the cloud.
So from an agenda today, I'm
gonna give a brief overview
of some AI services, and solutions,
and use cases for SAP.
Then we're gonna hear from Axfood
about how they're using
AI machine learning
to analyze SAP data and
their business processes.
And then we'll hear from Harman,
they're gonna talk about
how they're starting
their S/4 journey,
and how they're using gen
AI services to analyze
and transform with their ABAP code.
We will have some time for Q&A,
it's not gonna be live up on stage,
it'll be kind of behind
the seating area after.
So please stick around, love
to talk after if you have time.
Okay, quick show of hands,
who's first re:Invent?
First time re:Invent?
Okay, quite a bit.
What about more than one?
Quite a bit as well.
Good, good, good.
So for those of you attended
last year, or even in 2023,
if you attended any sessions
about gen AI for SAP,
very different message last year
than what you're gonna hear this year.
Last year we had a lot of
questions from customers,
what can I do with gen AI?
What are the possibilities
that you could do with gen AI for SAP?
And we showed a lot of demos
in art of the possible.
Fast forward to end of 2025
and we now have real customers,
like you're gonna hear
with Harman and Axfood,
sharing real stories
about the value that
they are bringing now.
So 2025 is a very pivotal
year where we started the year
with a few customers
that were early adopters.
We had a lot of customers that
were doing proof of concepts
or evaluations.
But you fast forward to the end of 2025,
we're exiting the year
with a lot of customers
that are moving gen AI
solutions into production.
We're starting to see mainstream adoption
of many gen AI services, and a lot of,
you know, other kind of
production ready services
that we have ready to go.
This was made possible
by rapid advancement across a few areas.
So first is the maturity
of large language models.
I'll call out Anthropic.
We use Anthropic Claude,
their Sonnet model,
quite a bit, does a great job of analyzing
and interpreting SAP data
as well as SAP ABAP code.
The beginning of the year,
Anthropic Claude Sonnet
was on version 3.5, then it went to 3.7,
to 4,0, to 4.5.
Each of those releases
was a major step change
in the maturity and the
capability to analyze
and interpret SAP business context.
We also saw industry adoption
for some kind of open standards
and some protocols across the industry,
and adoption within AWS services.
So, for example,
you see MCP up there,
MCP, if you're not familiar,
that's Model Context Protocol.
This is an open standard that
when you build AI agents,
it shows you how you can communicate
with backend data sources.
We're starting to build solutions,
we have some available,
that use MCP to communicate
with SAP using the OData interfaces
or the ABAP Test Cockpit.
So, you know,
overall, very pivotal year 2025.
I'm really excited where we're exiting
and seeing a lot of customers
adopting gen AI for SAP.
And this will accelerate
further as we go into next year.
Okay, we have more than 200 services,
you've probably heard that before.
When you start to narrow it down to say,
"What are the main services
I should be looking at
for gen AI, for SAP?
Here's the short list.
There's more services
than just these four,
but these are the four core ones.
Starting on the upper left
is Amazon Q Developer.
This is an AI coding assistant.
It works across almost
all programming languages.
Does a very good job with all
of SAP's programming languages
and frameworks,
including their cloud application
framework CAP and WRAP.
Also works really well with ABAP.
We released an MCP server
called the ABAP Accelerator
just recently.
The ABAP Accelerator allows you
to do some really interesting
use cases with Q Developer.
For example, it will
automatically generate
unit test cases for your ABAP code.
It will also take legacy ECC code,
automatically convert it to
be S/4 compliant code, right?
So Q Developer overall can really help you
on your S/4 journey.
If you're moving to CleanCore,
there's a lot of interesting
use cases that can help,
and then a lot more beyond that.
Upper right is Amazon Quick Suite,
in that family of services
also is Q Automate
and QuickSight.
Quick Suite, this is an AI
business intelligence platform.
It allows you to aggregate
data from multiple sources,
such as your own emails, your own files,
as well as interface with
enterprise data like SAP,
Salesforce, ServiceNow, and a lot more.
Once you gather the data, you
can chat with it agentically.
You can drill down, you can
build your own dashboards.
You can even build your own
agents with Quick Suite.
And we're seeing some
really interesting use cases
customers are starting to build
to automate accounts
payable, accounts receivable,
month end close processes
using Quick Suite.
The bottom two, Amazon Kiro,
you'll probably hear a lot about Kiro
this week at re:Invent.
This is our new agentic IDE
or integrated developer environment.
We're seeing some really
interesting SAP use cases
with Kiro, such as
building BTP applications,
or Fiori, or UI5 front end.
And then Bedrock and Bedrock
AgentCore on the bottom right,
Bedrock is our main AWS service
for integrating with large
language models like Anthropic,
or Amazon's Nova models,
or even OpenAI now.
And then Bedrock AgentCore,
this is a runtime
environment for AI agents.
So you could build AI
agents, run 'em in AgentCore,
and allows you to deploy
them into a highly scalable,
highly secure, highly
performance runtime environment.
We have sessions
and workshops this week
on all of these services.
We have sessions that are
SAP specific, and of course,
we have some that are
not SAP specific as well.
So if anyone has any
questions about any of these,
come find me after the session
and I'll point you in the right direction.
Okay, so without further ado,
I want to get into our
customer success stories.
So Gustav, I would like to
bring you up to the stage
and hand it over to you.
- So Eric, thank you for the introduction.
Axford is a leading food retailer
located in Sweden, Europe.
We are on the other side of the ocean,
where the time difference is nine hours.
So I'm here at midnight right now.
We have around 800 stores
and meet millions of customers every week.
Axford is one of the top 60 companies
on the Swedish stock exchange.
Our company consists of different brands,
and our customers, they
recognize us as supermarkets,
grocery stores, convenience
stores with different logos,
different prices, different concepts.
We operate both within
B2B and in B2C businesses.
We are a family of brands,
but we share common
operations when it comes
to purchasing,
logistics, business development,
IT, and other supporting functions.
Our market share is continuously growing.
We currently sell about 25% of the food
that is being sold in our country.
This means that both growing volumes
and keeping a tight focus on our costs
is key for our success.
Since retail, especially food retail,
is a business with high
volumes and low margins.
So we try to standardize
whenever possible.
Our SAP landscape consists
of a vast amount of systems.
Mainly we're running SAPS S/4
and SAP CAR.
And SAP S/4 we're running
the industry solution retail
as an add-on.
This means that we can keep
much of our master data in S/4.
So we keep our articles, our assortment,
our prices, our promotions,
our sales orders, purchase orders,
inventory, and point of sales data in SAP,
besides the traditional
ERP data, of course.
For maintaining our forecast,
we're running SAP EWM and SAP FnR.
Besides traditional ERP systems,
we're also running sub commerce cloud
and sub success factors.
Here we keep our eCommerce
orders, our employee data,
and our content services.
Looking at a process view,
we can categorize our systems
into different application layers.
S/4 is the basis of many
well-established flows.
We do a lot of custom development
in S/4 as well, though.
SAP CAR has got more unique capabilities
and it's used for retail
specific processes,
such as merchandising,
and assortment planning,
and promotion planning.
CAR is the abbreviation
for customer activity
repository, by the way.
So it's got most data objects
besides customer data.
It doesn't have customer data.
We keep our customer data outside of SAP.
AWS is used to enhance our
systems with analytical AI,
AI machine learning, and
composite applications.
We also keep our data stack on AWS.
The systems on AWS typically have
a shorter application life cycle.
I've also depicted some other
SAP systems to the left,
depending on their uniqueness level.
So we manage our SAP suite ourselves.
We're currently running
the the SAP S/4HANA
on premise edition.
Without the involvement
of any third parties,
we've got own staff, own employees,
and do everything ourselves.
Our business processes
that need differentiation
are custom developed in ABAP,
and have been so for quite
some time, over 15 years.
We've got full control
over the code, logic,
and the development.
We're building integrations on SAP BTP
with integration suites.
To give you some numbers,
our HANA database is over
six terabytes in size.
We are running over 4,000
CPUs and 140 virtual machines.
So going into our use cases, well,
in retail, many flows
are about moving goods
from point A to point B.
We also handle fresh items.
So we really need to have the stuff
at the right place at the right time.
Therefore, a lot of our focus
is on optimizing forecast and volumes.
We currently have more than
100 machine learning models
in production.
We anticipate that we can get
around 30% better accuracy
in our custom built models
than we get in our standard systems,
especially when it comes to irregularities
or deviations in our flows.
This is because we can build them up
with more history and more data.
We are currently running
around 20 different use cases
in forecasting for both
stores and our warehouses.
Furthermore, we use simulations
for our assortment planning
and use forecasted volumes in combinations
with customer data to
get the desired outcomes
for both us and our suppliers.
In e-comm, AI helps us to
deliver the relevant products
for our customers.
By using AI, we get better stability,
better sustainability, less food waste,
and a positive impact on the environment.
A few examples of our optimized flows
are being realized by
traditional machine learning.
We use ML for campaign
forecasts, seasonal forecasts,
sales forecasts, and e-commerce forecasts.
A simplification is that all forecasts
that require more data
than we keep in SAP,
they're custom built.
In our warehouses,
we optimize where to place items
depending on how much they're sold.
In that way, we can get
the shortest picking routes
for our manual pickers.
Regarding e-commerce,
we personalize the user experience online
and in our customer journeys.
This is done by building
models with article relations,
for instance, related items,
and predicting the next best action.
This can be used to
drive cross sell, upsell,
and other forms of recommendations.
Our shopping baskets are
normally around 50 items.
So clicking add to basket 50 times
is quite a hassle for our users.
So everything we can do
to simplify the user experience
is of big value here.
We also present users
with their most commonly purchased items
and inspiration on what
their peers are buying.
In our assortment planning,
there is a constant tug of war
between different parameters.
We use simulations a lot here.
For instance, we simulate what happens
if you change the price,
your volumes are probably
gonna go up somewhere,
but then again, another
item will sell less.
So we try to optimize
for the optimal outcomes
with machine learning models
in our assortment planning.
We improve our customer
offers by creating clusters
of customer groups,
and we also allocate personalized offers
for our customers to
bring them to our stores.
In our support functions, we
make data-driven decisions
and we share aggregated sales
data with our suppliers.
We never share customer data,
but we share it on an aggregated level.
This helps our suppliers
plan their flows better
and it also helps us get
our flows better in turn.
We also use a couple of AI models
for our internal decision making here.
Of course, we're also using gen AI
for employee productivity tools,
such as chatbots and similar applications.
Another example of gen
AI usage that we built
is a design tool for creating images.
It's a fine tuned stable
diffusion model on Bedrock,
trained on our design
language of our own brands.
We gave this to our business
and they played around with it
and actually created package
designs for milk cartoons.
These are actual items that
were sold in our stores.
Well, this was all
about bringing attention
to what can be done with AI
and also got our leadership on
board with what can be done.
So awareness in departments outside of IT
was a key benefit here.
So how did we get here?
Well, our SAP history
started way before 2010.
We started building our
current data layers in 2012
when we introduced a loyalty program
and an enterprise data warehouse.
A few years later, Axfood
decided to go into e-commerce.
We needed a solution that could scale up
and scale down according
to our purchase patterns.
So this was when we
introduced AWS back in 2014.
Being on AWS made us see
amazing launches like SageMaker,
Lambda, Fargate, and other
cool technology within AI.
So we decided to place
our entire AI platform
on AWS a few years later.
However, running AI in the cloud
and having a warehouse on prem
wasn't really a perfect solution.
We got into scaling issues
and decided to move our
entire data platform
to AWS back in 2022.
Since then, we've been building
lots of innovative solutions
and composite applications
on top of both SAP and AWS.
As you can see, our cloud
journey started in a small corner
of our company with e-commerce
and currently covers most major processes.
So, since we introduced our
loyalty program back in 2010,
we had needs for creating
traditional reports.
Well, we introduced the principle
to export all data, SAP
data and non-SAP data,
into our data stack.
On top of our data stack, we run AI models
and return the results,
either as machine learning
models through APIs
or as result sets back into
our enterprise systems.
It's a simple picture, but I'm
gonna go into more details.
So one key part of our AWS AI stack
is a self-service platform
that we call Mimer.
Mimer is a suite of AWS
tools, mainly SageMaker
and Airflow.
We both create and run ML models in Mimer.
We also use auto ML
to choose the optimal
machine learning models
and produce optimal
results for each use case.
With Mimer, we can build data pipelines,
either from manual files,
through third party
data from our warehouse,
or even through web scraping.
All data is imported into S/3
where it can be used for
further AI development.
Our data scientists
work in SageMaker Studio
and can explore large amounts of data.
We prepare inputs in SageMaker,
we train models, evaluate results,
and deploy artifacts.
When results have been calculated,
we return them either as
machine learning models
through APIs or as result
sets into our source
or into our target systems.
Currently our data stack has grown
from being just a data warehouse
into an entire data ecosystem.
Data is generated in
our application layer,
mainly in our SAP systems.
After that, it's integrated
through the integration layer,
either through EventBridge, EventMesh,
or integration services
from CPI as messages.
When data lands in our BI stack,
we use DBT and Glue amongst others
to calculate our ETL and data layers.
On top of the BI layer, we
place our machine learning layer
where we can do traditional ML with Mimer
or generative AI applications
with our AI gateway.
On the bottom of the picture,
I've depicted our analytics layer
where we use MicroStrategy
to analyze data from our warehouse
and sub analytics cloud to go
directly to our SAP systems.
So our data stack is
continuously evolving.
Some of the key points
for future extensions are,
better focus on data integration with SAP.
We always want to have more data
in our data warehouse layers.
We also need to improve our
business with more AI models,
more real time and new use cases.
A lot of our focus right now
is on building data products.
Building data products also
requires data governance
and has an impact on our semantic layers,
which are continuously evolving.
Furthermore, we need to support the world
of agentic AI better than we do today.
So we have an initiative
to look at MCP servers
and other technology to
have our data AI ready.
Finally, we need to do
some re-architecture
of legacy systems, for instance, SAP BW.
Finally, I would like to introduce
some of our lessons learned.
We've treated data as a foundation
for improving our business since 2012.
This has led to a long-term focus
of building multiple layers of data.
Data needs to have a single
source of truth, be clean,
and ready for AI.
We also introduced some high
value use cases early on.
This made our leadership introduced
into what can be done with AI.
When our leadership was on board,
we got a lot easier to get funds released
and to create the teams
for the necessary machine
learning developments.
Last of all, I would like to thank AWS
for the amazing AI
technology that we're using
and for the enablement services
and good collaboration.
I would also like to
reach out to my colleagues
and say a big thank you.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, thank you, Gustav.
Stay up here, though,
I have one question for you.
- Sure.
- I love your story, thank you.
You were early adopters in
gen AI for SAP or AI for SAP.
A lot of the work you did
started before mainstream
adoption of large language models.
Could you just share a little
bit about your thoughts
about transitioning from, I'd say,
some of your homegrown
machine learning models
and what you're thinking
about with adopting
some of the large language
models in the future?
- Yeah, so we are already looking into Q.
We're using that for
development in all our teams,
be it SAP or non-SAP right now.
We are also looking at the world
of agentic AI, like I said.
We really need to get more
generative AI use cases
on board with agents.
So that's really an area for exploration
for the future for us.
- Awesome, awesome.
Well, thank you again for coming here
- Thank you.
- and sharing
your story with everybody.
- Thank you.
- Okay, so next here we
have Harman International,
so I'd like to bring
Varada up to the stage.
- Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Varada Reddy,
I work as Director of SAP Technology
at Harmon International.
So thank you, Eric,
for the introduction and Gustav
for the nice presentation.
So first I'll start with a quick summary
of what my company does
and then I will explain
what are the SAP products
we are using at Harman International,
followed by our S/4HANA
implementation approach.
And then I will highlight
one of the key challenges
we faced during our S/4 implementation,
and how we solved it with AWS capability.
So a brief introduction about my company.
So Harman International
is a global company,
specializes in connected
audio technologies
providing audio systems in automotive
and consumer divisions.
So it is headquartered
in Stanford, Connecticut.
And the company was
founded about 75 years ago,
and the parent company
is Samsung Electronics.
The company was acquired by
Samsung Electronics in 2017
and since then it has been
part of Samsung Electronics.
So some of the well-known
brands of Harman International
or JBL, Harman Kardon, AKG,
and also there is a recent
addition, Bowers & Wilkins.
You might have been familiar
with some of these products.
And the company has two
major business segments.
In automotive solutions,
the company provides infotainment
systems, ADAS systems,
and connected car platforms.
And in consumer audio it
has headphones, speakers,
soundbars, and multi-room audio systems.
And also, professional solutions
is a subdivision of lifestyle division.
So which provides audio
equipment for studios,
and live events, and
enterprise environments.
So let me give a quick overview
of Harman's SAP applications.
So we have two SAP ECC landscapes,
both are running on ECC 6.0 and EHP 7.
And we have SAP BW for data warehousing.
And we have IBP for SIOP,
supply chain planning and optimization.
And we have SAP Ariba
for indirect procurement.
And we have BPC and BW 4/HANNA
for planning and consolidation.
And then we have several
manufacturing, integration,
intelligence and manufacturing
execution systems
for managing the operations
at global plants we have,
manufacturing plants.
And then we have BTP,
a business technology
platform on business.
BTP, we have integration suite enabled
and also we are using
some of the other modules
for build process
automation, build work zone,
etcetera.
And we have above the data services
and information for data
profiling and cleansing.
And we have SAP GRC for user provisioning
and governance and risk compliance.
And we have supplier business network
and some of the SAP technical solutions,
like solution manager
for change management,
custom code lifecycle management.
And NWDI for Java development
and portal systems.
And let me zoom a little
bit on our ECC landscape.
So we have two ECC
landscapes, as I mentioned,
both of them are running on ECC 6.0/EHP 7.
And as I'm going to highlight
a problem very specific
to custom code,
so I'm only covering the data
that is related to customizations we have.
So we have 30,000 custom objects
in one of the ECC landscapes
and on second landscape we
have nearly 20,000 CBOs.
And as part of S/4 migration,
these are the key considerations we have.
So we wanted to improve
some of the business process
running on SAP ECC environment
as part of S/4 migration
to improve the efficiency
of those business process.
And also, we have a finance
transformation plan.
So as part of this finance transformation,
the goal is to improve the
enterprise architectures.
And as part of that we are planning
to consolidate some of the company codes
and harmonize some of
the chart of accounts.
And also reduce the technology debt
by getting rid of some of unused
or low used third party solutions
or replace it with standard
S/4 functionalities.
And also get rid of some of the unused
or less efficient interfaces
and improve the code and configurations.
And also another goal
is to reduce the database
footprint significantly.
So even with regular archiving
on the current ECC environment,
we are unable to reduce
the footprint significantly
beyond certain extent.
That's mainly due to a lot
of third party related tables
have grown rapidly over
the period of time.
And also, several custom tables,
which are not part of the archiving scope,
contributed significantly
to the size of database.
So reducing the database
footprint is another objective.
And then another objective
is reducing or streamlining
the custom code we have
by eliminating unused customizations
or replacing with standard functionalities
wherever possible.
And one of the drivers to
reduce the database footprint
is downtime minimization
during the go live.
So as our manufacturing
plants are operating 24 by 7,
downtime causes business impact.
So reducing the downtime
to a weekend is necessary.
So coming to Harman's S/4
implementation journey
in specific.
So as I mentioned, as
one of the key objectives
is to reduce the data footprint
and also do the finance transformation,
improve the business process,
we select two data transition approach,
so as part of this we are migrating
only the open transactions along
with master data and customizing data.
And as part of the finance transformation,
like I said earlier, we are planning
to consolidate the company codes,
harmonize the chart of accounts,
and adopt SAP best
practices wherever possible.
And then coming to the customer
object rationalization,
the objective is to
streamline the customizations
by eliminating the unused code
and replace less efficient custom code
with S/4 standard functionalities
or improve the efficiency
of the code, etcetera.
And the landscape build is being done
with Shell approach.
So we are using SAP DMLT
services to migrate,
to select two data from ECC
source to S/4 environment.
So as I just mentioned,
one of the key challenges
we have is as our ECC systems
were implemented more than 25 years ago,
and over the period of 25 years
we have added a lot of
customizations in the system,
and majority of those customizations
have very poor documentation,
and in some cases very
minimal documentation.
So it is extremely important
to clearly understand
what are the customizations
we have today in the system
so we can efficiently
migrate it to S/4HANA.
And also we can understand what to test
and where there is a
possibility to replace
some of those customizations
with S/4 standard functionalities,
and also where we can adopt
some of the innovations
available from S/4.
So this determines the need to document
all those customizations
which are in place today.
So some of the key
objectives, like I said,
eliminate unused custom code.
So after doing the initial analysis,
we determined that nearly
40% of today's code
is not even in use.
So that requires a thorough cleanup.
And then we have a requirement
to analyze the interfaces
and dependencies as a lot of programs,
which were developed as part
of building the interfaces
for the systems connected
with ECC environment,
we need to clearly
understand the dependencies
so we can take care of
all the interface mapping
and dependencies, etcetera,
when we migrate the code from ECC to S/4.
And also another objective is to identify
what are all the
simplifications happening in S/4
and where we can eliminate
some of the customizations we have.
So as we built these customizations
over the period of 25 years,
so meanwhile SAP might have released
a lot of those functionalities
as standard functionalities
with subsequent ECC releases itself,
and some of them may be
released as part of S/4HANA.
So having good understanding
of what we have today
will help us to understand
what are the standard functionalities
which can replace some
of the customizations.
And another advantage of documenting
these customizations is we can limit
the testing effort by clearly knowing
what is really important for business
and what is being used, so
we can focus on the testing.
And also, when we are
troubleshooting some issues
as part of SIT and UIT,
we clearly understand the dependencies
and the purpose of the code,
so we can troubleshoot it quickly.
So not doing this documentation
will have a business impact,
because it can bring in
operational inefficiencies
and escalating costs as we
have to focus on more number
of objects without clearly
understanding the purpose
of the current code,
and also missed
opportunities for innovation,
without knowing what we have today,
we cannot adapt what is
available in the future release.
And there are also integration risks,
like I mentioned earlier,
if we don't understand the dependencies
and mappings in place, so we
cannot take care of those.
Also, it has a strategic importance.
So with fully documenting
and eliminating unused code or replacing
with standard S/4 functionalities
wherever possible,
we can optimize the system performance
and reduce the cost of ownership
even with the future upgrades
because we have less custom
code footprint to deal with.
And we clearly understand
where there are risks
and what are all the key areas to focus.
And then, even with future releases,
with clear documentation
we can quickly adopt
whenever there are new standard
functionalities available
and replace the existing customizations.
So with all this clear understanding,
we know that now we have to document
all 30,000 customer objects,
so there is no alternative for it.
So initially we started documenting
the custom code manually.
So there are some key
challenges with that.
So we started with six consultants
and started documenting.
So the performance was very poor
and it was very, very time consuming.
So in order to meet the project timelines,
so we initially planned
to achieve this in less than six months,
and as we were not meeting the goal
with the rate of speed
with six consultants
working on the documentation,
we ramped up the size of
people working on the task.
So we ramped up to 12 consultants.
Even with that there is minor
improvement in the speed,
still the estimation to
achieve the goal was 15 months.
And the cost of paying 12 consultants
for the period of 15 months
is expensive, as you know.
And also, the consultants
were collaborating
with several functional
teams to understand
the purpose of the code developed
over the period of 25 years,
and trying to document,
and it was very inconsistent
and missing the uniformity
because each person was
documenting in different format,
and it's not providing the
value we were looking for.
So these were the practical challenges.
And then we thought, this
is not working at all.
And also, we were unable
to meet the timelines
for the subsequent tasks planned
based on this documentation,
like mapping this custom documentation
with business process,
documenting or linking it
with the L1 to L4 process,
like order to cash,
regard to report, etcetera.
So the plan was to use this documentation
and association with
different business processes
during the unit testing, also
during SIT, UIT, etcetera.
But this was not working.
So then we looked at
alternative opportunities,
how we can solve it
with less manual effort
and how to bring in high consistency.
So then we started exploring
the AWS capability,
mainly we started with AWS Bedrock tool.
So the initial output from the tool
was not up to the expectation,
even though it was doing automatically
and it was only producing
the technical details,
like it scans the program
and provided only that tables
that program was utilizing
and few technical details.
Then we collaborated with AWS team
and significantly improved
by improving the prompt
and outputs, etcetera,
and then we were able to
achieve what we wanted.
So by utilizing AWS
Bedrock to quickly scan
all 30,000 objects at a rapid
speed significantly helped us
to achieve the goal within a short period.
So the speed compared
to the manual processing
was much, much higher.
So the speed has improved
by six to seven times
and reduce the total timeline
from 15 months to 2 months.
And the total cost
reduction was more than 70%.
And the outputs are very
structured, easy to interpret,
and very consistent.
So this is all achieved with AWS Bedrock.
And later we tried Amazon Q Developer
with a latest version of Claude Sonnet
and it was even providing better output.
So let me show you a quick sample.
So on the left side,
what you see is the
manually generated output
by the 12 consultants.
So this is one of the
sample program output.
As you see, it is very
difficult to understand
unless a technical person looks at it
and completely puts effort to understand.
It is very difficult for a business person
or a functional person to understand
what is the purpose of the code.
And what you see on the right side
is the AI generated output,
it is very structured.
So the top four or five
lines, if you look at,
it provides a key summary,
and then in the bottom it provides
business scenario
description of the program.
So when a business person takes a look at,
he can quickly understand
what is the purpose of this
program and understand,
as it is written in business language.
And then what are the key functionalities?
So if one of the SAP functional
team member looks at it,
he or she can quickly understand
what are the key
functionalities of this program.
And then in the bottom, as you see,
so this is a detailed
step by step documentation
in technical perspective.
So if an above developer
wants to understand each
snippet of the code,
he or she can take a look at this
and understand the complete functionality
of the code in technical terms.
So you see the difference.
So the right side, AI generated output
is very easy to consume and
also is very consistent across,
because same prompt was used across
all 30,000 customer objects.
So the output was very
structured and very consistent.
So one of the key lessons
learned based on this is,
so whenever you are dealing with some task
which is highly manual,
and highly repetitive,
and consuming a lot of your resources,
think AI as the first option
and see what are the
possibilities available from AWS,
and evaluate thoroughly if
you can automate it completely
or at least reduce the
manual effort to some extent.
And then think about manual effort.
So in our case, as it took
some time for us to explore,
I want to share this
lesson learned with you,
so if you're going through S/4 journey,
whatever may be the task
you're dealing with,
if it has high manual effort
and repetitive in nature,
think of AI as an option.
That's all from my myself, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, thank you.
- Thank you.
- Okay, thank you, Varada,
I have a question for you as well.
I know you're on a multi-year journey
for your S/4 journey,
and what you're doing with
gen AI, analyzing ABAP code
is part of your kind of assessment,
your early phases of the project.
How are you thinking
about use cases for gen AI
for the next phases of your S/4 journey?
- Sure.
Some of the use cases we
already started evaluating
is unit testing in
development environment.
So after we do the code remediation,
we are using a tool called SmartShip
to automatically remediate the custom code
in S/4 environment.
And also, as part of our
finance transformation,
we need to do some
functional code remediations
as we are con consolidating
the company codes
and harmonizing the chart
of accounts, etcetera.
So we need to do some functional
code remediations as well.
So post that, we need
to perform certain level
of unit testing in
development environment,
which is highly manual.
So to reduce the effort in unit testing,
we would like to use
MCP capability of Amazon
to automate some of that,
so to quickly scan the remediated code
and see it is consistent, and efficient,
and compatible with S/4HANA.
That's one of the use cases.
And also another use case
is whatever the new code
we develop as part of S/4 implementation,
we'd like to use Bedrock or
Q Developer to document it.
So manually documenting
the new custom code
can lead to inconsistencies,
and the developers sometimes,
if they're lazy, they don't fully document
all the data that's required,
and later it becomes very
challenging to troubleshoot.
So to maintain that consistency,
we would like to introduce those tools
and make it as a mandatory
step for all the developers
to use those tools with a
specific, predefined prompt.
So that way all the programs
will have mandatory details in place,
which can be easily referred later
for troubleshooting or
making further enhancements
in that code.
That's another use case.
And third one we are thinking of
is using agentic capability of AWS
to scan historical
transactions in ECC environment
and capture the data used
in different transactions
and use the same data in automating
the testing in S/4 environment.
So manually generating those test data
is a big task and difficult.
So if we are successful in doing that,
it'll significantly help
in automated testing.
- Yeah, got it.
Cool, well, hey, thanks for the answer,
thanks for presenting here today,
and I look forward to hearing
how the next couple years
of your S/4 journey go.
- Thank you.
- So, thank you.
- I would like to take this
opportunity to thank AWS team
for their significant help on utilizing
some of these AI capabilities, thank you.
- Thank you, Varada.
Please do go into the app
and complete the survey
and hope you enjoy the
rest of your re:Invent.
Thank you for joining today.
(audience applauding)